guys welcome to north american
counter-strike in 2020
where cs go esports are completely
eurocentric
where top tier orgs are blocking and
deleting the scene like it was a bad
ex-girlfriend
where young superstars are calling it
quits after basically being relocated
an ocean away from their home so
is nacs actually dead
just watch the video
all right guys before we go any further
you know what i'm gonna say if you
haven't already hit the sub button
and ring the notification bell so you
know when we post new videos which we do
all the time
and speaking of new videos if you have a
hot news tip for the don't at me team
you can reach them at tips at
thescore.com
you never know it might become a video
well it's 2020
and i cannot believe that we are still
talking about
is nacs go dead i honestly thought we
were past this i mean after
cloud9 won the major after team liquid
solidified themselves
as the best north american
counter-strike roster of all time
after premier orgs like 100 thieves and
eg were excited to jump into the scene
come on so why are we talking about it
is it because tarik tweeted that nacs
goes dead
of course not i mean not really
okay kinda but whether or not you
actually took tarik's tweets seriously
the sentiment that nacs
is dead did resonate with a lot of
people and there are reasons for that
let's start with the bombshell
announcement from earlier this week
that hundred thieves is pulling out of
cs go
again nadeshot himself came through with
a video to let us know that his org one
of the premier north american brands
when it comes to esports and streaming
one with deep pockets and big investment
was leaving the scene why because
hundred thieves is an
n.a-based org and that right now is
becoming a problem
in counter-strike and what's happening
right now in cs go
everything is transitioning over to
europe so as we talk to our players
and and discuss what options they might
have it ultimately
led to we need to be in europe and for
all the reasons that i talked about why
we want them in la and why we want to be
able to be there for them
for any problem big or small we can't do
that
we cannot provide that for them while
they're competing in europe
and we did not want to stand in their
way of the success of their careers
see the problem all stems from cs go
having to go completely online since
covet has really gone super saiyan
around the globe and that has led to
regionalized competition
like esl one cologne being literally
four separate tournaments
and those are four separate online
tournaments whose competitiveness and
entertainment value
are vastly less than one single
land tournament now that's bad for
competition and bad for viewership
nobody likes that not the tos not the
teams and not the fans
so what do you do do you ship your whole
squad to europe and essentially relocate
well look what happened to complexity
they originally went to europe to boot
camp but
never came back because they were afraid
if they did they get stuck in the u.s
and they'd miss all the big land
tournaments problem is
as it turns out there never were any big
land tournaments
and as this clip from complexities
through the smoke documentary series
shows
by the time they found that out it was
just too late
yeah so we played here at hydra for esl
pro league he got
moved to online because of the corona
outbreak
it's pretty weird because i've never
really played a big term like this with
so much
prestige online it feels weird and i'm
not gonna say it doesn't feel serious
but definitely feels like
not the same the end result
unfortunately for them was their young
american superstar oboe
leaving because he couldn't continue to
semi-permanently live an
ocean away from his home his friends and
his family
it definitely puts me in a weird spot
because i'm not really sure
when i'd be able to go back to back to
my home country
uh when i'm most of my family and stuff
like that it's weird because we don't
know how
how bad this chronovirus situation is
gonna get and in late september he
dropped a twitlonger saying quote
with talks of lockdowns and chaos
returning in the uk
and with no end in sight i was not
comfortable being so far from home
during this volatile time
i never expected to live on a european
team it was one hell of a year but
i couldn't handle it anymore i gave it
my absolute all but i underestimated how
much i
valued having time at somewhere that
feels like home
end quote it goes without saying that
losing this kid who
is just 17 and already pretty much a
bona fide superstar
is a huge blow to the team even so blast
premiere just announced this week that
their fall series
would not be a regionalized competition
that means
one big mix of teams from na from europe
and beyond
playing in europe online and look i get
it
we all want the best competition
possible we all want counter strike back
but wouldn't you know it almost
immediately after that announcement was
made
team liquid came out and said that they
would not be attending the first half
of that european event and honestly who
can blame them they're a north american
roster that probably doesn't want to
semi-permanently relocate to europe
speaking of which consider cloud9 the
only north american orc to ever win a
major is competing in europe in
flashpoint
season 2 and henry g has stated publicly
that they'll be planning to stay in eu
for the foreseeable future
now that is a c9 roster by the way
that's made up of one american and
four non-na players so with tos pushing
the need to relocate to europe to
compete with the best
na teams have a couple options one
they can semi permanently relocate to
europe
and take all the hardships and problems
that come along
with that or two they can just
not go and miss out on some of the
premier events in counter-strike
so if you're an org who doesn't have
deep enough pockets to
do that relocation to europe or like 100
thieves you
just don't want your team half a world
away on a semi-permanent basis
it's not a good scene right now
but there is another potential problem
on the horizon beyond today's
eurocentric
scene travel issues and visa problems
and that is valorant think about it for
a second 100 thieves
nrg tsm all premier north american
esports orgs
all without a counter-strike team
anymore all
with a valorem team and let's not forget
about t1 a joint american and south
korean orc and
sentinels both with valorant teams and
neither
seeming interested at all in cs go
valorum
is quite simply the new hot [ __ ] right
now not to mention
that it's specifically designed to be
more attractive to sponsors than
cs go and a ton of cs go talent has
already jumped shipped for greener
pastures now at first you might say
well colin a lot of those guys are more
middling players who
never really were able to break into the
elite echelons
of cs go but lately that honestly seems
to be a little less the case
with guys like six skadoodle hiko even
nitro
jumping to valorent but the real worry
here isn't so much these older guys or
these
middling players going to valorent
although i will say that nitro leaving
cs go was a big shock to me at least
it's really more about the next
generation of players
think about it if you're a 16 year old
pub star in 2020
and you're looking at the cs go
competitive scene in north america
you probably don't like what you see
some of the big fresh new
exciting orgs that you want to be a part
of are leaving cs
or don't seem interested anyway guys are
getting stuck overseas indefinitely
and all eyes are on europe right now
valorant on the other hand is expanding
and i mean rapidly all of these n a orgs
are aggressively
actively looking to get in on the ground
floor of the world's next big
fps esport and you could be their next
signing and
honestly valorent itself is just new and
shiny
and exciting and csgo is an
eight-year-old game
with some archaic features and a bad
anti-cheat and look you might be sitting
at home right now saying well i don't
like valerian and i love cs going it's
the best and despite all its flaws
it is the premier fps esport it's gonna
go on forever
and i might even agree with you guys but
the point is
you have to admit that right here right
now there are two
big boys in the world of competitive fps
esports
competing for the next generation of
talent
no offense to my siege people out there
you're right bommy bastard
so is nacs go actually dead
no it's not but it is facing a tough
challenge that might set it back years
at this point once the world gets back
to normal
if it ever does and counter-strike isn't
so eurocentric anymore
we can start rebuilding but the question
arises will the region's top orgs even
want to fight that battle
when the time comes and as far as the
long-term health of the region scene
goes
when valorant really gets a foothold in
north america
will it just lure too much young talent
away from counter-strike
these are questions that unfortunately
only time
can answer all right now that we're at
the end of the video who cares what i
think let's find out what you guys think
when i asked on twitter if cs go n a is
actually dead 100 thieves is out it's
dead jim
that's a star trek reference if nacs can
come back from the nuclear catastrophe
that was the cgs
then it can come back from this it'll
just take time
another optimistic tweet essa tag just
joined c9 it will be all good
bro we still have chaos liquid
and gen g right now guys crying face
guys and the best of them all from
sadakist
kovid caster's coaches competition
the four that killed counter-strike